it's time Viktor time you discover the
hero
[Music]
you should probably leave Victor stone
aka cyborg he's a college athlete a
quarterback for Gotham City wasn't an
accident
and was severely injured to save his
life his father merged his body with
advanced alien technology
half-machine but he's all superhero
cyborg is totally unique
I've been doing some tracking what
you're looking for sticking to the dead
zones no no let's gonna do what you do
you can find them use a technopath he's
able to interface with any form of
Technology
relax Alfred don't take it from here uh
do I know you you can the transformers
body in the different weapons we're
gonna bring in the big guns
those are very big guns cyborg is the
perfect combination of the power of
Technology and the strength of the human
heart
we need your Viktor maybe you need us
he's ready to help save the world
never a dull moment you guys better
watch out justice is coming
hey everybody new Justice League trailer
just hyping up cyborg and Wonder Woman
and their hunt for the mother boxes but
there's also a really big Superman
Easter egg in there that you may have
spotted so there's a new round of the
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on the video on us a new winner at the
end of this but there's a surprising
amount of new stuff in here and you can
kind of tell how they've started to
finish the movie they've color corrected
a lot of it so it looks way different
from the earlier trailers the colors
just pop a lot more like when the back
gate of the flank box comes down and
they all walk off we've seen this shot a
couple times but now it just looks so
much better that's all about
post-production but they answer a couple
of big questions in the movie like
what's happened to the mother box that
was used to create cyborg so part of it
is literally inside of him so it's
almost like Steppenwolf won't be able to
get what he needs from it without taking
some of it from cyborg but speaking of
which Steppenwolf shows up in a lot of
the scenes that are in this trailer in
the background like you see him down in
this warehouse here he fires a shot down
into Steppenwolf surrounded by a bunch
of parademons the way they cut it is a
little misleading because then they're a
bunch of big explosions going on right
after this scene and I don't necessarily
think that those scenes are happening
one right after in the movie
you also see him drop down into that big
tunnel fight sequence that we've seen
going back all the way to the first
trailer like the one where they all
jumped down into that big cylinder you
see a really good shot of Steppenwolf
here I'm guessing this is actually from
the nest of parademons we've seen a wide
shot of that and the more recent
trailers but in this scene here with
this red sky background on whatever this
is is either a ship or it's a building
you see Steppenwolf
crouched down behind him like he's
kicked his ass and he's taking off and
then you see the other scenes that seem
like they're from earlier in the movie
where Wonder Woman is trying to recruit
him for the Justice League no one can do
what you do we need help finding them
the things that you're looking for are
using the dead zones to travel the thing
he's probably talking about our
Steppenwolf in his forces traveling
through dead zones where they can't
track with satellites there are a couple
of funny Superman Easter eggs you may
have spotted these in earlier trailers
but they're just featured much more
prominently in this footage so you see
this police officer here that cyborg
saves somewhat early in the movie that's
mark McClure the original Jimmy Olsen
from the Christopher Reeve Superman
films hey do it Jimmy Olsen photographer
but he also came on the small Bell TV
show to play a Kryptonian during season
7 the funny thing about that is that
it's almost like the old TV actors from
the older Superman TV shows now get to
play Superman super-powered Kryptonian
characters in the newer shows like Erica
Durance Lois Lane from Smallville is now
super girl's mother on the Supergirl TV
show car car I love you Kara because of
the Earth's Yellow Sun you will have
great powers on this planet
you will do extraordinary things
you've never wanted Tom Welling to come
back and play a Kryptonian again on the
TV shows more than now and you may have
spotted this earlier but this is just a
different angle of it in Batman's
armored room here you see the new
tactical armor on the right side here
like he says he's bringing the big guns
out he's talking about the other Justice
League members but behind him here you
see this classic samurai armor which
reminds you of Michael Keaton Batman's
armor room where do you think that's
from Japan why because I bought it in
Japan but it's actually draped in a
kimono with Superman colors and I know
there are a lot of other theories about
things that he's looking at this is that
Alfred scene that everybody keeps
pointing back to thinking it's different
characters Supergirl there was a
Supergirl at one time in the ancient
history of the Snider vers version of
the DCE you but it's not officially
canonical to the film's I believe it was
included in some of the extra comic
books that they released with Batman V
Superman and Man of Steel so it goes way
way back and they haven't really
followed up on that so technically you
could say that there is a Supergirl
somewhere or there has been one on this
earth but as for all the cyborg stuff
honestly I think the future of this
character is best served in somebody
else's film before he gets his own solo
film supposedly they're still on track
to do a cyborg movie but I think that's
2020 it's a Green Lantern core territory
like they say they're doing a Green
Lantern movie but it's literally like
one of the furthest things off that
they're going to do they haven't even
announced that they're doing the second
Justice League movie they are working on
scripts but that just means that they're
preparing for whether or not they
actually do it depending on when it gets
made so depending on the success of this
Justice League movie you'll see Justice
League two either in like two or three
years or they could decide to wait to do
it till after they do a bunch more solo
movies after they do another Superman
movie obviously we know Wonder Woman 2
is coming they can wait as much as 4 or
5 years so I think it just depends on
how things go with this movie but early
tracking is going really well so you'll
hear more about that in the next couple
of weeks and I haven't had a chance to
see the movie yet but I'm expecting that
I'll get to go to a critic screening
sometime before the movie comes out so
whenever the embargo is up I'll do my
non-spoilery review but I think that's
going to be the week of the release
so it comes out on the 17th I probably
won't be able to post that non-spoilery
review to like the Tuesday of that week
so just a couple days before the movie
comes out which if I remember correctly
was the same deal with a Wonder Woman
movie which was pleasantly surprising I
think that they were worried that people
would hate it but everybody loved it so
they just moved the embargo up they're
like ok you can talk about it as much as
you want everybody go see it this is
gonna be great and it became one of the
highest-grossing DC films of all time
but let me know in the comments what do
you think about cyborg so far and which
movie do you want him to pop up in next
honestly I think the flashpoint movie is
probably the best place we already know
we're getting Wonder Woman in that so it
makes sense that they would include some
of the other Justice League members if
they're gonna do comic-book flashpoint
but what'll happen next is I have some
new Thor Ragnarok to post tomorrow will
be flash day so there'll be a whole
bunch of that congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Tam my boy please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you can click here for brand-new
reverse-flash and you can click here for
the trailer for the next flash with that
Batman name drop thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight